The pharmaceutical industry has an
important role to play in American
health.
First of all,
uh,
this is a lifesaving industry.
This is the industry that we hope is
going to be able to control Alzheimer's
and Parkinson's and these other diseases
of the elderly.
Uh,
so,
um,
we are dependent upon the pharmaceutical
industry,
but at the same time,
prescription drugs cost too much in this
country.
And we have to really move to generics.
We have to get costs so that they're
affordable for people.
We have to figure out a way so that the
pharmaceutical companies can make a
reasonable profit and people can afford
their drugs.
And right now we're not there.